hi folks welcome back to e3 2014 Max and
Shawn here and Shawn you just got to
look at what could possibly be one of
the darkest games at the show The Sims 4
I just sat in on a half hour sims 4 demo
in which they built up the personalities
of these two sims Yelp and the lives and
all the intimate details you really got
invested yeah and then they died in a
fire at the end because they were
laughing themselves to death so why is
that such a theme with this new sims
game because they show that as well in
the in the press conference brand it was
like you can laugh literally today so
okay so the official tagline of the
sense for is smarter sims weirder
stories and it seemed like really lean
leaning into the absurdity of like
different situations you can get
yourself into of your sims so basically
like you have a lot more control over
their personalities when you're creating
them wrecking like you can make somebody
who's like super cool and friendly or
you can make somebody who's a total dick
and then you choose like all their
little obsessive traits like this guy is
a foodie or this guy is a wine snob or
this guy is evil this guy's up and
that's gonna affect how they get along
with you yeah and essentially that
affects like how they deal with people
and like and all kinds of stuff like
that so when the demo started one of the
two guys was in like a really intense
rage because he had a dispute with
another sim earlier and just couldn't
get over it would not do deals one of
his traits was he just doesn't let go so
he was so angry that it unlocked new
emotion actions whoa one of them was
whoa rage work out so he did like rage
sit-ups push-ups no are those any
different from normal sit-ups push-ups
you just have a quick frowny face no
he's like on angry and just screaming
the whole time okay and then eventually
they go to the gym so he could really
get into it and at the gym they run into
chuck norris and chuck norris became his
mentor and of course Chuck Norris is
working out in jeans and
boots and those are just grafted to his
body at this point oh yeah definitely
and then eventually they decide to throw
a party and weirdly at the party they
have all the friends over there having a
good time but then the craigslist
roommate comes back from work and the
craigslist roommate is Kim jong-un why
Lizzie no North Korean dictator yeah but
in The Sims not somebody you want as
your roommate yeah and that's kind of a
dick and so they're like you know what
we gotta we gotta distract this guy
loves making cupcakes okay we're gonna
72 making cupcakes in the kitchen the
only problem is that it really sucks at
making cupcakes and he started a fire
and because these two sims their
personality traits were their bros and
they just laugh at terrible things
because they're awful people they were
laughing at the fire they're having a
good time with it and then they died
from choking on carbon monoxide Shawn I
gotta tell you this story that you dark
for me sounds like I'm a was like weird
just roller coaster of crazy that I
thought was gonna get back on the rails
at some point but it didn't yeah ended
with everybody dying in a grease fire it
well it may be not technically a grease
fire cooking fire of some kind but yeah
so it's it's really about like drilling
down into the personalities open Sims
and like the weird little social
interactions they can get into because
of their like very specific traits
you've assigned them when you created
them and it it's it's cool you know cuz
we all play sims at the end of the day
some people play the sims like a dick
yeah they like you know locking them in
the bathroom said they poop themselves
to death of course I can do and it seems
like they're just kind of taking that
general sense of absurdity and
extrapolating it to the rest of the game
and now there's all kinds of like
craziness you can get into but at the
same time you know it's still a sims
game they're still doing like actually
really cool interesting stuff like the
fact that you can download like
pre-built brooms that people have design
and then you just drop that into your
house ok and you do it so it's other
stuff like that more technical so it's
not just all the insanity and though
yeah it's not like a crazy absurdist
fever dream ok you know there are actual
improvements they're really leaning into
the ridiculous stuff at least in like a
PR campaign which sure yeah
totally well hopefully the rest of us
here at gamespot don't die in a horrible
cupcake related accident and we'll
continue bringing you exciting III 2014
coverage stay tuned one way or the other
life all right it'd be like Maxwell's
haze I can let's high-five real quick
yay nailed it